[Music]
what the [ __ ] is this cringy white empty
nesters
white in parentheses White
this is AI everybody this is AI dude
empty nesters up here in Cape Cod and we
are about to do a Duncan review damn
Jasper sucks at tick tock
Jasper is horror horrendous I think it's
killing it no because that's what you do
when you're you know swishing it up
all times empty nester we're learning
all about everything oh I [ __ ] I
[ __ ] love them bro I love them
swishing it up and having an all-time
ball
this is just AI we're just learning
everything we're Shook and woke and
[ __ ] and pissing
foreign
up here in Cape Cod so let's
just medium ice milkshake
dude this sounds like an AI it really
does what did you get Dad
delicious delicious milk chug delicious
medium ice milk sugar
even his [ __ ] face
bro lift those sunglasses up it's just
two red [ __ ] lights just two orbs
yeah
[Laughter]
all right and I got my fave unsweetened
ice cream I brought up my fave bro amen
the dude on the left is just learning
how to use his skin
tea no lemon because they don't have
lemon and Dunkin but let me taste
tasty delicious absolutely delicious so
cheers to emptiness cheers we miss you
kids okay not really no
no that's the AI bugging out nope
Cheers Cheers Cheers Cheers Cheers
Cheers Cheers Cheers Cheers Cheers
Cheers Cheers
oh man milk Shug
[Laughter]
damn
that's funny you think they meant to
post that on tick tock yeah
you think so yeah definitely yeah
yeah
go to their account yeah let's see what
else we got
ice milkshake
[Laughter]
she give me milk shook in the back seat
she'd give me ice milk sugar in the back
seat
talk like hey everyone leave Kanye alone
oh no
as alumni of BYU
I think our favorite drink is eggnog
this is this I love my new Yeezys yeah
this milk sug is almost as good as
eggnog
milkshook man milk shook
what do you put in your coffee milk
sugar man
nothing like an eggnog lemonade water to
cool you off
foreign
water I guess I guess water I guess I
guess milk nugget lemonade water I guess
milk nog yum
egg water
nothing like an egg lemonade with water
on the side
egg lemonade water I guess I guess egg
lemonade I guess
is the AI generated by BYU students yeah
yeah
that's [ __ ] good I guess Dr Pepper
eggnog I hit by a car I guess lemonade I
guess water
I'd rather smoke a vape than suck my
dick yeah what
uh it's not really working Finch
Finch me Finch me Finch me can I get the
finch and eggnog you just get one of
these just any one of them I just wanna
yeah hi everybody empty nesters here
coming back to you from Cape Cod cheers
we got some ice cream this time busy day
this time we only have to buy two ice
cream cones because we don't have the
three kids with us yep little Bed Bath
and Beyond a little uh TJ Maxx Little
Beach busy day today but now we're ice
creaming it up all right what do you got
I got peppermint stick and it's so so
awesome because man the way they talk is
so it's so passive aggressive for no
reason
dude the face he's making right now is
crazy you dear right he's trying out his
skin yeah [ __ ] gray alien right here
destroying all the features yeah he's
like this shit's tight
God damn I can't breathe in this [ __ ]
faces
he's like the skin is tight as [ __ ]
the [ __ ] am I eating
he looks
alien asteroids bodies rejecting yeah
yeah
God damn bro it's pink and
pushing waves coming at you with some
chocolate fudge well the way he's in the
bottom corner just
everything sounds like a lie uh I got
the uh whatever this is and it's pink
and pink is my favorite color that looks
like rough as the ocean waves
I have eggnog cream chocolate ice
kids are like
not another one you know what I'm saying
they're like friends are tagging them in
this they're like again stop it stop
with the empty nesters [ __ ] they're like
we're starting our only fans next week
I'm here with my favorite shook is that
I'm here with my favorite ball sack
I'm sorry okay
I'm here to give him that Harry Styles
treatment
dude absolutely Brownie and it's smooth
as our gravy sandwich all right all
right
bye that's actually really funny for
your parents to make social media and
all their content is like I'm so glad
those [ __ ] [ __ ] are out of here yeah
yeah we're having so much fun right now
like [ __ ] God damn why did we ever have
those pieces of [ __ ] yeah I gotta see
another one of these
hello everyone empty nesters here in
Connecticut what do you got our dunks on
mobile Monday getting that extra 100 I
gotta get those points what'd you get oh
milk and sugar milk and sugar
bro who is this uh who's that boy
this is Brent Rivera it is a 50 year old
yeah
damn dude